avec bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes bonsoir bertrand le grand
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france tout d'abord ce décrochage dans
l'accès aux vaccins en seine-saint-denis
est ce que c'est de nature à être
inquiétant lui bien sûr que c'est
naturel très inquiétants parce que le
gouvernement n'a toujours pas compris
comment on faisait pour faire vacciner
les populations les plus précaires et
les plus à risque on a exclu au maximum
les médecins généralistes de la
vaccination est aujourd'hui là où on a
mis le plus gros centre de france de
vacciner de vaccination le plus grand
vaccinodromes où on a le résultat qui
est le moins bon taux de vaccination il
faut remiser sur les acteurs de
proximité qui sont les médecins
généralistes et je vous rappelle qu'à
cette heure-ci moi je n'ai toujours pas
touché un seul vaccin type kaiser ou
modern a pourvu actionner des gens de
moins de 55 ans donc si dans les
quartiers populaires les médecins
généralistes ne peuvent pas vacciner
leurs propres patientèle
n'espérez pas qu'elles viennent prendre
un rendez vous sur un compte internet
pour venir alors même qu'elles sont
incapables d'honorer en général leur
rendez vous chez l'ophtalmo sont que
c'est pareil ça veut dire pour vous
qu'il ya une partie de la population
voilà qui n'ira jamais dansé
vaccinodromes on peut quand même le dire
pour une fois c'est quand même plutôt
bien organisé
sur place c'est très bien organisé sur
place elle est encore beaucoup mieux et
beaucoup plus efficace chez le médecin
généraliste du patient est ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les
populations les plus aisés le bobo
parisien comme on peut dire qu'ils se
fait vacciner les gens qui sont pressés
de partir en vacances et on voit bien
que dans les couches populaires l'accès
reste extrêmement difficile et c'est
négliger la difficulté de l'accès aux
soins du fait de l'éducation
c'est une constante on pense toujours
qu'il suffit de mettre de l'argent sur
la table pour que les gens se soignent
en réalité ce n'est pas un problème
d'argent c'est souvent un problème
d'éducation
le fait que vous ayez des vaccins father
et moderna chez les généralistes
est-ce que ça reste du domaine du
possible on a souvent parlé un des
problèmes de de conservation à des
températures très basses est ce que ça
va arriver un jour selon vous alors
j'aime votre incantations j'aimerais que
ça arrive
officiellement on est censé en recevoir
la semaine dernière mais le tableau le
camion semble être tombé en panne en
tout cas uniquement pour les libéraux
c'est vraiment pas de chance la
conservation banon c'est n'est pas un
problème puisque le kaiser qui était le
plus dur à conserver se retrouvent le
plus facile à conserver
puisqu'on peut le garder 31 jours dans
nos frigos classique j'irai de votre
propre cuisine
donc il n'y a plus rien qui empêche à un
généraliste d'utiliser de garder du
kaiser du moderna dans son cabinet par
contre ce qui nous empêche aujourd'hui
de vacciner les moins de 55 ans c'est
l'idéologie de l'état qui nous empêche à
nous à être doté d'un stock de vaccins
dédié aux personnes de moins de 55 ans
donc à cantonner les médecins
généralistes et les libéraux uniquement
à la vaccination des personnes âgées
effectivement ça risque pas de
progresser chez les récalcitrants le
plafond verra que craignent les
autorités
ce serait dû à ça ce que vous nous
décrivez aujourd'hui pour passer le
stade suivant
et j'ose dire la vaccination était très
ouverte à tous ceux qui le voulaient et
on a au moindre mot négligé mais plutôt
je dirais vexé l'ensemble des acteurs
libéraux et notamment dans leur manière
de prise en charge est effectivement
aujourd'hui qui va aller vacciner
la grand mère de 80 ans qui peut pas se
déplacer dans un centre de vaccination
c'est bien de médecins généralistes ou
son infirmier ou son pharmacien
donc à un moment donné si on ne donne
pas les moyens de le faire si on nous
donne dix vaccins par semaine
il faut pas non plus en même temps se
plaindre que les médecins généralistes
ne fasse pas au entre guillemets le job
lui ont fait pas le job on n'a pas les
deux donc c'est évident emmanuel macron
qu'annonce ce soir avoir été vacciné une
réaction
c'est très bien parfait excellente
nouvelle et pas grand chose à rajouter
effectivement l'horizon se dégage en
tout cas comme l'a dit jean castex moins
de 3000 malades en soins critiques
c'est une première quand même depuis fin
janvier c'est ces deux bonhommes qu
augure on voit quand même la sortie du
tunnel
bin oui oui c'est d'autant plus une
bonne augure que si on avait vu un petit
plateau il ya une semaine qui avait
l'air de se fixer sur les faons pour
cent mille à personne
le plateau a l'air de redescendre
maintenant ces derniers jours et donc on
peut espérer que on va aller chercher
cette femme plateau probablement que les
isolements se font un petit peu mieux et
j'espère qu'on va revenir sur ces
problématiques d'isolement car une
personne qui est toujours contagieuses
toujours avec plus de virus dans le nez
ne peut pas être libérée dogmatiquement
au bout de dix jours c'est quelque chose
que je répète depuis le début
et si on veut enfoncer ce socle qui que
l'on traîne depuis septembre il faut
aussi enfoncées l'idéologie qui nous y
amener depuis septembre à savoir l'
isolement de dix jours sans se poser de
questions alors cette décrue à leur
coller
les écoles l'école a repris 1 depuis
d'ailleurs plusieurs semaines maintenant
justement on préconise la vaccination le
conseil de la haute autorité de santé
préconise la vaccination des adolescents
et des enfants c'est une bonne chose
selon vous elle est indispensable c'est
nécessité fait loi
on va avoir du mal à atteindre 80 %
d'une population vaccinée sans y mettre
les adolescents parce que ça voudrait
dire qu'on atteint quasiment 100% chez
les adultes
or on sait très bien qu'on n'y arrive
pas et les moyens qui sont mis en oeuvre
ne sont pas des moyens qui sont de
nature à rassurer sur l'atteinte de cet
objectif là donc encore une fois quand
on fait une vaccination de masse en
vaccinodromes on atteint les 60% 70% de
vacciner maximum on n'atteint pas 80%
donc pour atteindre les 80 90 % qui sont
nécessaires pour ne pas vacciner nos
enfants est très clairement il faudrait
il faudrait que les médecins libéraux
soit à la manoeuvre ce qui n'est pas le
cas donc du coup lyon va élargir un
petit peu et puis on rendra de plus en
plus insupportable la vie à ceux qui
refusent de se vacciner pour au final le
rendre obligatoire sans le rendre
obligatoire parce que politiquement
parlant on peut pas dire obligatoire
donc on trouvera un nouveau mot mais
chut voilà à quoi je pense que hébert m
haies est très fort pour inventer de
nouveaux baux donc j'ai hurlé c'est le
choix de deux chevaux pour préciser un
c'est la haute autorité de santé qui
doit rendre sa décision et 7 conseils
scientifiques qui préconise une dernière
petite question est ce que vous craignez
en france
la multiplication du variant indien qui
semble beaucoup embêté nos amis
britanniques en ce moment le variant
indien comme tous les autres variant ne
connaît pas de frontières et on peut
toujours imaginer que nous mettons en
place des mesures strictes qui
empêcheront le variant d'arrivée s'il
variant est plus contagieux il va se
diffuser
la seule chose qui va le freiner c'est
la capacité à rencontrer un obstacle cet
obstacle c'est la vaccination
voilà et on n'arrête pas un virus avec
des mesures que faut arrêter si beaucoup
bertrand legrand médecin généraliste à
tourcoing merci d'avoir été avec nous